d'un bruxelles au deuxième jour du
sommet de donald trump a de nouveau tapé
du poing sur la table et réclamer un
meilleur partage du fardeau des dépenses
militaires
comme d'habitude le président américain
a soufflé un peu le chaud et le froid
sur ses partenaires est bon quand même
un possible retrait de l'organisation du
traité de l'atlantique nord
mais tout à l'heure pour les conférences
de presse le ton avait changé il était
plutôt à l'apaisement on écoute emmanuel
macron je pense que l'otan semble
beaucoup plus forts de ces deux jours
parce que d'abord nous avons acté des
décisions importantes
nous avons acté dès réaffirmer une
stratégie budgétaire crédible et qui
correspond à nos besoins nous avons
aussi et puis échangé hier sur les
nouvelles menaces
pour moi être un des éléments les plus
importants de la stratégie qu'on doit
déployer l'otan sort beaucoup plus forts
ne dis le moi les en français après deux
jours quand même ça pas mal tangué
oui exactement mais deux choses d'abord
je trouve que le emmanuel macron a été
bon dans cette affaire et dans sa
communication est dans son rôle de
négociateur je crois qu'il est un peu
calmé le jeu et notamment il a joué le
pont entre angela et donald je crois
qu'il faut pas non plus toujours se
faire avoir par le cinéma trump c'est à
dire que s'il a un côté quand même
j'allais dire je voudrais pas être
offensant pour quiconque meabe son côté
un peu bateleur vendeurs de tapis qui
fait qu'ils montent les enchères avant
d'arriver et ce qu'ils voulaient obtenir
c'est quoi c'est que les européens
s'engagent fermement sur cette question
d'augmentation du budget il a dit sinon
je m'en vais sinon et je veux 4%
il a dit cap pour avoir viré obtenir
directement et je crois qu'on l'oublié
un peu toujours c'est un mode de
négociation qui est très peu quai
d'orsay on est d'accord très peu
département d'état qui est souvent je
reconnais très surprenant et qui peut
être très dangereux dans certaines
circonstances mais je pense qu'il faut
pas non plus surestimer la folie de
l'homme dans cette affaire je crois que
là il ya un côté plutôt joueur de poker
tu en es kuzmanovic vous êtes très
critique à l'égard de l'otan on a
retrouvé la dernière interview à donner
vous parlez de bras armé de l'hégémonie
des états unis affaiblir l'otan c'est
pas dangereux mais dangereux pour qui
mais nous sommes les français nous avons
une des meilleures armées au monde et
nous avons en plus ce parapluie
nucléaire qui nous protège ainsi que nos
partenaires européens
donc je vois pas de danger
de qui à part le danger qui nous menace
tous ce qu'est le terrorisme mais auquel
on répond par des procédures de police
de justice et de renseignement militaire
non non moi je suis d'abord entièrement
d'accord avec ce que vous avez dit je
conseille à tout le monde de lire ce
petit livre excellent de certain donald
trump qui s'appelle tu remportes dit
même que la résiliation et c'est
exactement il théorise il faut créer une
ambiance chaotique comme vous avez un
rapport de force et il faut forcer pour
gagner plus
il applique ce qu'il a fait toujours
dans en tant que j'allais garder
commençaient à s'user un peu cette
technique de m le rapport de force il va
prendre forme il coachait quand il
faisait affaire les auteurs vont finir
par les voies revenus mais pour le
moment les interlocuteurs ne résiste pas
la dernière résistance organisé l'une
européenne ça a été en 2003 avec
villepin et schroeder contre la guerre
en irak s'est il y avait un axe vraiment
franco-allemand de dire non c'est
absurde et cet axe avait raison là
maintenant on est dans une situation où
ai-je oui je confirme
l'otan est dangereux pour pour pour la
paix on l'a vu avec l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
on le voit j'ai lu là il hier soir le
rapport du compte rendu du sommet de
l'otan
mais c'est délirant c c'est une mise en
guerre contre la russie etc
ces furieux en fête et à la fin il va y
avoir un gros problème
on peut en ce moment il ya 2600
véhicules blindés américains qui sont
des pays à l'est on améliore vrille les
routes les ponts les pour déployer plus
de trop la pologne a déployé 6 4 4
milliards de dollars c'est colossal de
batteries anti missiles alors les russes
riposte il déploie alors ils déplorent
leurs missiles nucléaires et skander
juste enfin on est on est à la crise des
pershing des années 80 c'est dangereux
lente la situation où on est et
dangereuse l'otan est dangereuse pour la
paix exactement la même rhétorique
alexis si le vestiaire dans les collèges
où quelques raisons de se méfier qui
peut des russes alors ça explique bien
des choses
cela dit je crois qu'il faut reconnaître
que premier mis le doigt sur les choses
devraient quand il dit que les
américains financent la force protection
la vérité ça fait depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale que ça se passe comme ça
on est obligées d'acheter du matériel
autant lourds fabriqués aux états unis
et il conclut nous vendre nos rafale par
exemple intéressant quand on veut les
vendre
ils viennent ici plus forte quand même
si tu achète des rares regardez regardez
unis vont de l'algérie à part la france
qui est un vrai budget de défense et
jusqu'à la plaza de mayo menons sinon
les pays européens ne consent pas
financièrement l'effort de défense qui
permettrait qui leur permettrait de se
défendre et vivre sous le parapluie
américain
c'est les américains qui les défendent
mais contre ça coûte beaucoup de mais je
vous dis pas que c'est bien je vous dis
que vous reconnaître la vérité mais
j'avoue ne pas que sans les américains à
1 3 million d endroit qu'il faut qu un
mais je vous dis juste que sous les
européens allaient me tuer même plutôt
dans votre sang on se dit que le wifi à
moi il faut que les abris car ce que les
européens voient la vérité que
aujourd'hui depuis la guerre ce sont les
américains qui assurent notre défense et
qu'on peut pas prétendre 500 kg et de
contrepartie les 90 et une dépendance
vis-à-vis des etats-unis faut pas se
raconter des blagues et donc du coup
donald trump utilise ça parce qu'il est
malin parce que c'est un homme
effectivement de rapport de force il dit
on vous paye pour vous et bien sûr les
négociations commerciales parce que
c'est pas que sur la défense demandait
déjà les négocions commercial édiles
police vous allez vous allez mieux nous
parler bon la seule solution c'est que
effectivement si on veut prendre en
compte à son objection que vous faites
et qui sont légitimes
ça veut dire qu'il faut que les
européens se défendent eux-mêmes elle
fume même l'emprunter de ce qui serait
assez d'ailleurs étant désormais m
mais sauf que sauf qu'il ya un an il
faut payer ici aujourd'hui les payer les
américains seront alors on est à un
point que lui pas comment il faut passer
à 2 mais pour d'autres pays et
tactiquement les allemands sans de ça en
volume se voit peu près la france et
l'allemagne pourcentage du pib c'est un
peu moins en allemagne mais alors là le
sentiment des français est partagée par
ceux à peu près les européens enfin
musulmane les européens sont plus
européens que les français sur la l'idée
qu'il faille et une politique de défense
commune s'est on est à 75 % pour
l'europe l'an dernier eurobaromètre sur
l'ensemble les européens sont 14% pour
les français presse à bari l'allemagne
est très favorable à cela
évidemment
les britanniques beaucoup moins
naturellement il ya bien cette attente
c'est le défi qui est posé par le nouvel
le nouveau des équipements die parce que
les européens voient une menace à l'est
pour le coup il ne trouve pas poutine
extrêmement rassurant mais il trouve pas
non plus 30 exe extrêmement rassurant et
d'ailleurs et c'est un des éléments qui
fait qu'on regarde aujourd'hui l'europe
un peu différemment c'est constater
qu'il ya quand même un bien un espace de
stabilité ici mais qui dont on aspirait
ski s'autonomise emplettes et est ce que
il ya une coïncidence entre cet espace
politique et cette défense mais à quel
prix les questions effectivement pas
pris la prochaine guerre ça sera en iran
on a déjà on a une opération il ya un
mois dans le nord de la grèce dans des
pires parce que les côtes line ressemble
à celle de deux là où se trouvent les
installations nucléaires iraniennes
et il y avait un entraînement autant
avec les états unis la grèce et israël
f 35 22 ans bombardements en rase mottes
bon voilà c'est ce qui nous attend jeu
c'était effectivement un problème pour
la paix et je vois pas en quoi ça nous
protège
ça va nous entraîner à nouveau une
guerre qui pour le coup je vous le dis
franchement vous savez tous très bien
pour l'économie sera catastrophique s'il
y ranger entre les roches en éclairant
toujours la palme d'or vous votre
comparaison et piercing est intéressante
parce que c'était la même rhétorique à
l'époque alors que je vous rappelle que
l'initiative était venue des soviétiques
qui avait installé les 16 20 et on
présentait les pershing comme une
agression américaine alors que c'était
qu'une riposte américaine justement et
c'est elles veulent comparer messi ont
droit oui sur l'europe il faut bien non
parce qu'il ya eu un réarmement russe
colossal depuis 20 ans vous le savez
donne hélas nous l'otan représente 80% à
dépenses de guerre mondiale alors sur
l'europe
et sachez une chose très importante la
chose juste donné un faire un point
factuel beaucoup de pays ont ré
équilibrer leur budget en économisant
sur la dépense militaire depuis 20 ans à
cause évidemment de la fin de la guerre
froide et notamment tous les dykes
d'europe du nord l'allemagne etc
donc on à renier sur les budgets
militaires pour entretenir en fait
l'état providence et et le reste de
l'économie
il est quand même normal qu'au bout d'un
moment il ya un réalignement parce que
depuis vingt ans le monde a changé
je sais que pour vous lire on n'est pas
une menace l'iran est quand même
inquiétant sur certains plans la russie
est inquiétante la turquie est
inquiétante
il est normal que l'europe se défendent
je serai aussi plus
vous pour une défense en europe et au
centre et est en effet les européens
vont un peu dans ce sens et c'est
nouveau ça mais quelques quelques
réponses pour d'abord à notre question
en général selon vous donald trump est
une raison au sujet de l'otan c'est très
partagés vous êtes 51% à dire que non
charlotte nous dit trump a raison de
demander plus d'efforts de la l'europe
sauf que c'est de l'hypocrisie car il
veut juste faire sauter la baraque
lolo dylan ou 10 trump a raison aussi
mais il se bat pour les intérêts des
états unis avant tout qui est pas cela
fait de 1991 que l'otan aurait dû être
dissous et amir l'europe pourrait-elle
assurer sa propre défense on a un peu
abordé ce sujet effectivement j'aurais
juste qu'on entend alors c'est plus sur
le climat de ce sommet de l'otan
toujours la conférence de presse des
manuels macron ce matin c'est en fin de
matinée il revenait il était interrogé
sur les tweets de donald trump et le
climat entre les alliés de l'otan j'ai
entendu des commentaires
j'ai lu des messages à 140 caractères
mais j'ai assisté aux débats les débats
n'ont pas été de cette nature il n'y a
pas eu de stigmatisation de manque de
respect c'était des débats respectueux
actifs et exigeant c'est de la langue de
bois
quelle langue de bois je suis pas
certain peut-être qu'il a aussi
contribué encore une fois à la place ben
moi je suis je trouve que ça se termine
mieux qu'elle n'avait commencé et je
pense encore une fois que trump a obtenu
ce qu'il voulait et donc en effet
finalement ça se termine pas dans une
crise comme on l'avait vu d'en haut j'ai
vite par exemple
non non je pense que cette affaire a été
bien mené et par train et je suis reçue
par emmanuel macron tenteront d'obtenir
ce qu'il veut éliminer la france aussi
en un sens parce que la france est en
train d'obtenir un réveil européen sur
la défense et ça fait quand même très
longtemps qu'on le demande la
contradiction ou bien trempé ce qu'il
veut c'est de faire payer les auteurs ou
bien il ya mobilisation européenne pour
dire non
sans toi mais maintenant on va pas me
payer pour le faire mais si me réveille
au plan européen qui consiste à donner
de l'argent à l'otan pour permettre un
tram de financer son affaire ça me
paraît pas une extraordinaire
manifestation d'indépendance européenne
l'on peut dire tout ce qu'on veut mais
non ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il doit
y avoir un équilibre un réquilibrage que
ce soit mais ça peut prendre des formes
tout à fait varier un cet effort
militaire peut prendre des formes
on parle on parle de 2 % des forces de
défense on parle pas de 2 2% de
contribution à l'otan c'est une autre
chose et ça veut dire que les pays
peuvent très bien il est venu tordre le
bras long cdc forme de bras parce qu'on
a besoin de lui parce qu'on n'est pas
d'accord entre nous parce qu'on n'a
probablement pas les mêmes intérêts
stratégiques et que les intérêts des
polonais mais qui craignent la russie
parce qu'ils sont à côté d'eux et de
l'ukraine et de la crimée tout ça tout
ça ça les inquiète et on peut les
comprendre ne sont pas les mêmes que
ceux des italiens ou des grecs ou des
français dont le problème se situe sur
l'habitat n'est pas du tout en russie
parce que franchement les russes ne
menace pas nous donc on l'europe est
extrêmement divisé ce qui se passait
quand même me semble-t-il très
préoccupant pour l'europe c'est que
allait diviser les américains sont en
train de se retirer de cette affaire-là
ils se rendent compte que c'est plus
tellement pour le sujet que le sujet
c'est jean je pense que leurs intérêts
seraient vis-à-vis de la chine est fier
de jouer une solidarité transatlantique
apparemment c'est pas l'idée de trump
qui considère qu'il faut donner en
direct avec avec les chinois mais c'est
vrai que l'europe au mieux tout ça étant
est extraordinairement affaibli et
l'affirmation faso l'amérique je la sens
pas trop quand même on est attendue en
allemagne à l'automne
même les choses sont simples l'empereur
est arrivé et le proconsul des gaules a
eu un discours de vassalité non mais
quand on avait un vrai dirigeant en
france comme le général de gaulle le
projet qui est mis en place actuellement
c'est à la communauté européenne de
défense parce que c'est strictement la
même chose il a c'est la france qui a
refusé et il a réussi à conserver
l'indépendance de la france là on
capitule est il actuellement l'europe de
la défense
vous ne pouvez pas me trouver
sincèrement on a réduit un moyen
précieux un seul texte où que ce soit
d'ordre la défense qui n'est pas pensée
dans le cadre de l'otan ça n'existe pas
pour les raisons que la vie il n'y a pas
d'unité géopolitique donc la seule unité
géopolitique et ça c'est bien vu dans le
programme de mâcon il avait aucune
programme international
vous pourriez il fait partie des young
leaders ces voix là dans les questions
géopolitiques celle des états unis qui
gère les affaires
basta et son discours s'est même pas de
langue de bois il est honnête je pense
que le brésil a peu changé depuis 1960
je pense que justement la dalle est une
autre contradiction c'est devant des
amériques et à l'impérialisme et veulent
se retirer vos choix pour choisir un
mois je pense que henrik ajoute beaucoup
plus sur une pente de sortie de l'europe
de sortie de l'europe c'est pour ça que
je dis que ce n'est pas du tout
contradictoire si nous payons plus ce
sera pour notre propre défense et on ne
peut pas dire que c'est fini 1960 des
américains c'est on n'est plus à
l'époque de kennedy nixon les américains
n'ont qu'une idée et c'est pour ça que
l'invasion de l'irak tout ça ce sont des
références qui ne tiennent plus les
américains ne veulent plus envahir
l'irak ils n'ont qu'une idée c'est parti
toutes ces régions
écoutez écoutez écoutez bush face et son
programme tant le rapport de l'otan il
est spécifié soi que ces articles 59
j'allais lui ce n'est encore une fois ce
matin l'article 59 dit que l'otan envoie
envoyé des forces en irak vous assurer
que ce sera surtout des américains à
cause de l'iran voilà je ne sais pas
sûrement et oui c'est sûrement à cause
de l'iran qui prépare la guerre à venir
également
alors ça c'est vrai c'est exactement ça
à dire ok pour le crime et mais tu t'en
radio tu t'en sais si pressés à raison
la vraie
d'importance à faire un conte donald
trump venir ceci annoncé lundi chez eux
c'est cette rencontre qui arbitrera
entre d'entre nous soit vous trouvez moi
un crédit cadre et avec qui notre hub
mais la france